there was a horrible and tragic shooting
over the weekend in a sense it was
really sort of to mass shootings at Al
Noor mosque and at Lynwood Islamic
Center mosque in Christchurch New
Zealand at this point we believe that 50
people were killed and another 50 people
were injured we know that the alleged
shooter is a 28 year old white
supremacist who lives streamed the first
attack has been arrested and charged
with murder and as soon as we got our
hands on the alleged shooter 73 page
manifesto that he left behind it became
very clear that whether or not this
shooter was specifically motivated to
violence by Donald Trump as an
individual there was no doubt that the
rhetoric and ideology that was
compelling to the shooter matches that
which we've seen coalesced by Donald
Trump and this is effectively undeniable
and there have been all sorts of
defenses which we will talk about
momentarily but when you look at the
manifesto and you see the conspiracy
theories that there's a white genocide
happening or about to happen when you
see the extreme anti-immigrant sentiment
describing himself as an
ethno-nationalism us looms referencing
Donald Trump as a quote symbol of
renewed white identity and common
purpose those who want to separate Trump
from this incident point out well hold
on the shooter wrote in their manifesto
that they don't support Trump as a
policy maker it's not a defense okay
just I mean cut it that that's just a
ridiculous defense every white
supremacist
says that they don't see Trump as a path
to white supremacist policy they see him
as generally renewing and fomenting the
conditions and atmosphere in which white
supremacy has a better chance of growing
and expanding when I interviewed white
nationalist Richard Spencer a couple
years ago at this point
he literally said it to me in almost
those exact words during an interview
it's not that Trump is going to do the
thing it's that he's the closest that
they've had and he's sort of allowed
this environment to foment so those who
want to separate Trump from this
incident say the shooter was an eco
fascist who believes in global warming
hate to break it to you
most people believe in global warming at
this point especially in the rest of the
developed world climate change I should
better call it in the United States
right-wing extremists often don't accept
the climate science but in a lot of the
world you can both recognize that
climate change is real and still be a
right-wing white nationalist extremist
in the United States
it's where the two seem to go together
only very rarely but most importantly we
don't have to just look at what Trump
has said before the shooting and then at
what the shooters manifesto said even
after the shooting in New Zealand Donald
Trump continued to use verbatim the same
language of the shooter visa vie an
immigration invasion Trump said oh yeah
it's a horrible thing of course and then
he immediately turned back to
immigration and the language of calling
immigrants an invasion which is exactly
the rhetoric of the shooter we actually
have a bit of video here of Donald Trump
talking about this and you will see him
very quickly go back to the same stuff
that seems to have motivated the shooter
it is a tremendous national emergency it
is a tremendous crisis last month more
than 76,000 illegal migrants arrived at
our border we're on track for a million
illegal aliens to rush our borders
people hate the word invasion but that's
what it is it's an invasion of drugs and
criminals and people you have no idea
who they are so understand what he's
saying here the shooting was bad but the
shooter was right in that there is an
immigration invasion this is the
rhetoric that has pervaded the 19th
century in 28th 20th century xenophobic
movement
but it matches up Trump and the shooter
the New Zealand shooter and Trump using
almost identical language the New
Zealand shooter saying we are
experiencing an invasion on a level
never seen before in history Donald
Trump not only sang people hate the word
invasion but that's what it is but
Donald Trump clearly believes that this
is a worse quote invasion than we've had
in a long time because he declared a
national emergency around it one that is
absolutely an utterly bogus the relevant
mechanism here is called stochastic
terrorism I've spoken about this before
this is when you publicly demonize a
person an institution a group and what
happens statistically is the likely
motivation of an individual to commit
violent acts it's statistically probable
but you can't predict who will do it
when you think back to that right-wing
host Glenn Beck who maybe you've
forgotten about at this point and when
he would always go on and on about the
evils of the tides foundation it was not
a terrorism in the sense that he was
specifically telling an audience member
to go and try to attack the tides
foundation but his audience was big
enough that it became statistically
likely that someone would be inspired to
commit violence against the tides
foundation and indeed someone did and
they were caught I believe it was with
weapons on a highway before they were
actually able to commit that act of
violence stochastic terrorism is the
term here and incredibly I'm going to be
talking about it twice on today's
program including in the next story one
of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the inner
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below